we're going to begin this hour with
something that you're going to see only
on cbs mornings i have to say we really
do love when that happens oprah's
revealing the latest selection for her
book club this month's pick you could
say is a bit of a departure for her the
author shares her life journey to help
readers find their own most fulfilling
path in life
lead national correspondent that's david
bagnow sat down with the author and with
oprah who said i'm so glad i get to talk
to david to hear all about it
good morning i am so excited to have
this conversation i've got the book in
my hand and the lady who made the pick
on the other end of the line joining us
now from hawaii is oprah i have to tell
you in reading the book oprah there were
so many aha moments for me happening
left and right
same for me that's why i chose it i read
it and there were so many ahas i thought
wow wouldn't it be great if i could
choose this for book club and then
thought no
it's not a novel
but why not i get to do what i want so
the next book is the way of integrity by
martha beck
who has been a spiritual
counselor guide for me for years with o
magazine
and
has shared her words of wisdom over the
years and has really compiled it all in
this wonderful book that i think that is
so
needed and meaningful for our time the
way of integrity by martha beck
well said and joining us now is martha
how does it feel to hear oprah rave like
that about the book i don't know i left
my body about five minutes ago i'll let
you know later no
it's
i think the greatest honor i've ever
felt let's talk about the weight of
integrity the title of the book what is
the way of integrity
it's
an alignment with every part of one's
own self
so there are different ways we make
meaning body heart mind and spirit and
when all of those are
in harmony with each other it's like a
machine in structural integrity right a
plane in structural integrity can fly if
its parts are misaligned it can't fly it
may crash it may not take off and when
our parts are misaligned
when we're not integrity one thing but
when we're divided
from ourselves in duplicity or
multiplicity we don't fly either
and oprah in picking the book the fact
that it wasn't a novel was there
something about it that you felt was
right for this moment this time that
we're living in well one of the things
that i think we're missing in this
moment is
integrity in many phases of our lives
and i think that that starts with each
individual instead of trying to tackle
the world's integrity i think it starts
with each person looking within
themselves and it's about
aligning with the truth of you you know
i i pride myself on being a person of
integrity and as i was reading i was
thinking about the ways in which i am
not you know the little white lies you
tell the conversations you have that are
really where you're not 100 fully
present there and every single one of us
we're born in perfect integrity
but we get pressured before we can even
talk
to do things that aren't maybe in
alignment with our nature so most people
who are out of integrity are trying very
hard to be good
and they've followed the culture
whatever their culture is their family
their ethnicity their religion they're
following that sometimes away
from
their truth the expression of their true
nature and they get split
and suffering is the inevitable result
one of the things that martha teaches in
her book is about soul teachers soul
teachers are sometimes the irreverent
loud people who we kind of tell to get
out the room because they're not
conforming to what the rest of the room
thinks is right yeah they may not be
loud but they're weird and here's why a
person who is in complete integrity is
by definition different from the culture
and that is the definition of weird but
those are the people who can break the
illusions of culture in our own psyches
and teach us to find the truth within
ourselves and i love the line where you
say
the soul teacher outside of you will bow
to the soul teacher within you always
always
every single real soul teacher will tell
you ultimately
you
are the source you talk about your truth
and you write in the book about leaving
the mormon church yeah and coming out as
a lesbian yes
what has that done for you
oh my goodness talk about leaving
culture and being weird and everybody
saying get out of the room
it's the most liberating thing that
could happen
are you kidding i had grown up mormon i
had never considered myself gay i was i
was going to be a good girl according to
my culture and i was really my mind was
fully in it
so when i was 29 i decided i wasn't
happy i wasn't happy
but they told me that the truth would
set me free so i decided when i was 29
on new year's eve that i would not tell
a single lie for a calendar year
and i kept that resolution
and i ended up leaving the religion
i realized i was gay so they weren't my
marriage i didn't like my job quit that
my family of origin
out the window but at the same time
there was a wholeness growing
deep inside me that i had never felt
before in all of my years of talking to
people there are so many times when
people are
wanting things and wanting a life
that really isn't designed for them but
they're wanting it because the culture
says you're supposed to have it and she
speaks so profoundly about what you want
versus what
you really need to make yourself happy
martha will you share with our with the
audience cbs audience here what you were
talking about how peace is really our
home and when you start
even saying that to yourself how it
changes
immediately emotionally how you feel in
your body so i've coached literally
thousands of people all over the world
all stations of life what i've found is
that every person i've worked with
murderers
beggars billionaires they all feel
an alignment with their sense of truth
when they say the phrase i am meant to
live in peace
so everybody out there who's watching
this
think in your mind i am meant to live in
peace i am meant to live in peace
experiment with believing that
and feel how everything goes
yeah
because that's true for every single one
of us oprah what's the book
the way of integrity by martha beck
she is so excited about this book and
and as we've been saying all morning it
is a very different pick for her because
she always she doesn't normally pick um
uh nonfiction books but she said i
started thinking uh it's called oprah's
book club i'm oprah shouldn't i pick
what i like she really really likes this
book because she thinks integrity is
missing in many levels in our lives and
maybe this book will be a whole helpful
and hopeful reminder to others you know
martha revealed something else to us she
said that she's almost 60 and she's
raising a one-year-old um with her
current wife rowan and her former
partner karen and they're all
co-parenting under the same roof with
martha's older son adam and it's a
modern family she said she wrote about
it in the book but she said the editors
asked her to take it out why why because
they thought it was too much information
and i thought and i thought wow wait a
minute here's this wayfinder guru martha
beck that's talking about how we can
live our purpose-driven true life and
she's being told
you're a little too much yeah it's a
little too much that's the culture and i
thought whoa and you said i can't wait
to tell it and you know what's funny
well no i first of all i got her
blessing yeah of course she did yeah but
she said to me after she told oprah and
in the interview she said asking when
you asked the question and i said it
i felt free
david because she addressed it david i
like that i am meant to live in peace
just hearing that for everybody yeah i
like that that's right i love that
that's awesome awesome thank you
thank you oprah
don't forget tonight oprah daily live
streaming that's right q a with oprah
and mark and martha that's right that's
right i was supposed to say that and i
forgot so that's all right thanks
throwing you a lifeline i forgot so no
so i thank you
hope for always talking to you we should
tell you that oprah will be speaking a
little bit later on with martha beck you
can watch a streaming event
over daily. good job girl
sometimes i need a reminder